all right welcome everyone to my first
round recap from the cter Masters it's
been a long day for me um I had a long
battle a very interesting battle against
International Master PR Vu Pala from
India and I want to note that I'm still
pretty chat lagged I just arrived in the
country I guess 3 days ago and today
I've been awake since 4:00 a.m. so if I
sound like I'm dying uh please please
forgive me maybe wish me well uh I do
look forward to sleeping after recording
this but uh let's get into the game it
was a
D4 opening and I actually decided before
the game that I would play a London and
I've been hesitant to play London in
classical tournaments uh at least over
this past year I can't recall if I
played London in
I don't think I played it in
be or
Vegas or KERO or rovic is that true is
this my first London of the year in
classical chess I did have one game in
Vegas which was some weird like Gambit I
guess it started as a London um where I
got the winning position after like
eight moves but yeah I've uh I've really
mixed up the openings over the course of
this year playing E4 and D4 and C4 and
Knight of3 but uh I stayed with my my
bread and butter for this game and
coming into this game I didn't have too
much time to prepare but I did have uh
maybe like 90 minutes to two hours and I
saw that my opponent plays this line
Bishop to D6 and I actually found a game
that my opponent played earlier this
year in
Baku where he won from the black side of
this position against none other than
Hans Neiman and it was actually a really
nice game from the black side uh Hans
played the move Knight E5 which is
actually my main prep and Hans played a
line where he pushes H Pawn early on and
he he basically played what I would have
played if I didn't see that game and see
how my opponent just dismantled Hans um
or at least neutralized Hans in the
opening and then one a bit later in the
game after Hans over pushed so after
seeing that game I had basic two goals
in mind one was to deviate from the game
with Hans and the other goal was to
avenge my uh my compatriot and try and
get some payback for uh my opponent
taking down the uh the famous Legend as
we all know in Hans nean so uh before
the game I was just trying to figure out
what my other options are because I
didn't want to be predictable with 95
and my opponent actually told me after
the game that he was preparing this from
the lack side so I chose a move here
which is not something I don't think
I've ever played definitely not in a
tournament maybe it's something I've
played like once or twice online uh the
main alternative I should note is Bishop
to G3 this is a move I used to play and
there's some other options like Bishop
D3 or Knight D2 leaving the bishop here
and um yeah these lines are popular for
white where white accepts double f- PA
to get a grip on E5 but I chose a move
here which let's just check the database
real
quick uh yeah I chose the third most
popular move in the Master's database
which is Bishop takes
D6 and at first this move looks like a
concession because I'm trading off one
of my only developed pieces and I'm
helping black activate the queen um but
the point of this move is to keep the
game relatively quiet and just have easy
play out of the opening and after Queen
takes D6 rather than going for the
traditional London like triangle
formation uh I transition into more of a
Queen's Gambit setup with Pawn to C4 and
the plan is simply to play Knight C3
Rook C1 get some space on the queen side
and um it's actually a very simple
position at least for the next few moves
from the white side let me hide notation
yeah to avoid spoilers but going forward
from here my opponent cast
I play Knight C3 and then he takes takes
and plays
C5 and at this point I was out of my
pregame
preparation but I was kind of expecting
to be out of prep early because there's
a lot of different branches black can
choose uh A6 is a move B6 is a move and
even going back here B6 Knight D7 C6 I
knew there's a lot of like possibilities
for black so after he played C5 I took
my first small think of the game um and
now I'm going to take my first small sip
of this
recap my throat is a bit dry so I'm
going to have to continually sip water
throughout uh the next probably 15 20
minutes um anyway C5 challenging the
center and here I decided to play what I
thought is the most flexible move just
castling uh leaving the tension between
the Pawns
my opponent plays Knight to C6 and here
I took another think and decided to play
a very ambitious move Knight to
B5 and the point of this move is of
course to harass the queen but also to
try and get initiative and I thought
there's maybe some possibilities where I
end up taking on C5 and then exploit the
D6 square with an eventual Knight D6 or
queen
D6 uh now unfortunately this didn't
really happen like I was not able ble to
exploit the square as I wanted because
after takes takes uh my Bishop's
attacked so I don't really have time for
anything coming to D6 like if I play
Knight D6 then I would just regret it so
I played Rook C1 here and yeah now of
course aligning with the queen but black
is in time to play Rook
d8 uh basically controlling the defile
now forcing my Queen off the defile I
play Queen E2 and then Queen E7 was
played and I saw this position from a
distance and thought okay it looks
Pleasant for white because black is
still underdeveloped on the queen side
and this is one of the points of of the
opening even though maybe it's not the
most testing opening theoretically uh
black does have some issues in
developing the lightw bishop and
basically What's Happening Here is white
has a temporary Advantage where if I can
really try and create some initiative
and capitalize on next few moves then
maybe black can be in trouble but if
black gets a few moves to for example
play like A6 and B5 and Bishop B7 then
black will be doing fine so I felt a bit
pressured here to try and make use of my
like early leading development my
slightly uh more active setup and I
played what I thought is a very
reasonable move Rook D1 getting my last
piece in play so all my pieces are now
developed and doing something but then
my opponent plays A6 I play Knight D4
and then we trade uh takes I take with
Rook takes and take and yeah I didn't
really see how to avoid the the
simplifications and then my opponent
plays E5 and it's a very useful move not
only hitting my knight but preparing to
bring out to the
bishop so I haven't had a chance to
analyze with engine yet I don't know if
I missed anything earlier to maybe get a
larger Advantage um but the game was
still super interesting going going
forward from here because after I play
KN F3 uh I was expecting Bishop to
G4 which my opponent didn't play I
thought maybe uh maybe he didn't play
this because he was scared of like H3
and some G4 ideas and uh perhaps black
doesn't want to take take and allow some
nice activity and Rook C8 is not
possible here because Bishop F7 tactics
so instead of playing Bishop G4 right
away my opponent played
H6
which after he played it I thought was a
logical prophylactic move like he's
preventing Knight G5 ideas which
definitely was an idea for me to hit
F7 um but here I I was very happy with
the move that I came up with um because
my next move move is a very
multi-purpose idea uh with Queen to
C2 and there's probably like two or
three purposes with this move uh for one
I'm getting off this diagonal so Bishop
G4 will not be pinning my KN and very
soon we'll see why that's relevant um
but in addition to that I am creating
the battery on the C file and there's
ideas of potentially just retreating the
bishop uh maybe E2 D3 or B3 and then
eventually playing Queen C7 and trying
to get some activity on Black's seventh
rank um there's also ideas here of using
this diagonal like for example black
can't play G6 because Queen takes G6
it's playable because now um yeah that
pawn is pinned and I also had ideas of a
very interesting Knight maneuver and
we'll see what plays out because after
Bishop to G4 uh I played the move Knight
to
H4 and during during the game I was a
little bit questioning myself uh with
going for this because it
seems a bit weird to just put my knight
on the edge like this but we're going to
see that this F5 square is actually a
really nice Square for the Knight and
it's very hard to stop Knight F5 again
G6 doesn't work because the pawn was
just is just hanging and uh yeah
meanwhile if I get to play Knight F5
then the Queen's harassed and um yeah
now the bishop is also in kind of No
Man's Land it's just staring into empty
space so the game continues from here my
opponent plays Rook C8 very sensible
move um I should note here that uh maybe
some people are watching and wondering
why I can't take on F7 and take the Rook
but the bishop on G4 does defend the
Rook on C8 so I don't have any immediate
tactics so I go for Knight to
F5 and my opponent takes um I had some
fantasy that if my opponent plays
something like some queen
move um let's say queen D7 there's a
cool idea to take take and then Queen G6
winning the Knight um so black did have
to be
careful so Bishop F5 was played and I
thought this was a small success to get
a situation where it's now Bishop for
Knight and my Bishop is quite powerful
on C4 especially and black has played E6
F7 is a constant Target um but the
downside for me in this position is
there's this annoying pin on the C file
and my opponent played a move here which
I wasn't quite expecting this move Rook
to C5 and I realized that I'm in a
little bit of a predicament because
black is threatening to play B5 and just
wind material so I had to be really
really careful here and um yeah
initially I wanted to play Queen
B1 but then Queen C7 and there's still a
pin on the C file B5 is still coming I
think if we entered this position then
white is losing some material um because
there's no clear way to deal with this
threat so I took some time after Rook C5
and I played the move Rook to C3 making
sure my Rook is defended by the pawn my
Bishop is no longer pinned my opponent
plays Queen C7 still creating the
battery I play Queen C2 and with this
move I am threatening to take on F7 so
my opponent saw that and plays King f8
so now taking on F7 no longer comes with
check and here I saw that um yeah black
probably wants to play B5 if he gets a
chance force my Bishop to move and then
take on C3 and damage my Pawn structure
so in this position I played what I
thought is a very logical prophylactic
move move Pawn to A4 and this
essentially prevents B5 because now with
B5 I'm happy to take take and take and
The Rook can't take the bishop because
of the pin so white would went a pawn in
this
line so instead of B5 my opponent played
Knight to E8 which is a weird looking
move but it's actually the move I was
expecting because the Knight wasn't
doing too much on F6 and yeah Knight D6
is a much better Square to pressure my
Bishop on C4
so here I played the move Pawn to
H4 um after the game I hopped on call
with Jonathan TR who was taking over my
twitch channel for commentary during
during the round and he was joking that
I played a delayed crab A4 H4 uh the
crab opening is not something to be
recommended but later in the middle game
sometimes these moves can come in handy
and H4 especially is actually a a
multi-purpose move because not only am I
making Loof avoiding any potential back
rank made ideas but I'm also having
ideas of playing H5 and we'll see this
later if I do get this move in then uh
it's a nice
positional um nice small positional
Victory I would say because I would have
one Pawn clamping down on Black's two
pawns and I thought that yeah black
should maybe play H5 here to get a setup
with H5 G6
um but that didn't quite happen my
opponent played Knight to D6 and then I
played Bishop to D5 so I did concede in
moving my Bishop allowing the trade on
C3 I wound up with um yeah some damage
structure but in return for the damage
structure I actually have a really nice
Bishop on
D5 uh what would xqc call this that's
called a wooden Shield bing bing boom
pal and the bishop is going to be
defended either with E4 or C4 very soon
so I was still feeling relatively
comfortable here um but it's in
imbalanced position because yeah Queen
and Knight versus queen and Bishop in
general Queen and
Knight should be more powerful than
Queen and Bishop but in this specific
position because my Bishop is active and
because there's pawns on both flanks the
Bishop is actually really useful in
controlling um both areas of the board
so game goes forward from here he played
Queen to C5 I play Queen B3 so just
harmonizing making sure everything is
defended and then Pawn to B6 was play
and this gave me a chance to play Pawn
H5 I was very happy to get this move in
uh because now yeah black can't get the
sellup with H5
G6 uh so my opponent plays Pawn to A5
I play Pawn E4 defending the bishop and
at this point I thought that maybe we're
just heading towards a draw because um
yeah we're getting a situation where
it's going to be difficult for either
side to find a clear plan uh but very
soon the position just explodes uh
within a few moves and I do want to note
that um yeah we're on move 31 here on
move 40 we both get an extra half hour
but yeah very soon both of us get in
pretty severe time pressure uh so my
opponent plays King E7 I play G3 simple
improving move and then he plays B5 and
when he played this move I thought it's
like very clear that he's trying to play
for a win in in this end game uh to
imbalance the position if black can
trade these pawns which he does after
takes takes pawns are traded then black
has the outside past a Pawn uh which can
be a very powerful asset uh in the end
game now thankfully for me my Bishop on
D5 does control the A2 Square in many
cases so it's not a huge concern of the
pawn queening so quickly but I did have
to be careful here and I definitely did
not want to trade Queens if I trade
Queens here then it's probably very
close to losing for white especially if
I have to play this move then the Knight
can come into D4 Pawn can start running
so I keep Queens on the board play Queen
A3 and yeah once I saw that I could
reach this position I was actually
feeling comfortable and I thought maybe
I have winning chances because now the
Knight is pinned and I'm threatening not
only some ideas of C4 with uh C5 to
follow but I also have some tactical
ideas that Bishop takes F7 because the
king would be overworked the Knight is
pinned so here I thought black has to be
very very careful
and we're seeing my opponent get very
low on time I think after the next move
yeah he was falling almost below a
minute and he played at five which in
the moment I thought is kind of a panic
move he's just trying to make things
chaotic but this turned out to be I
think a very resourceful move because
he's pressuring the ewn and really puts
a
question what to do here for white uh
the move I played is
C4 and then he plays Queen to
B4 and um yeah when I played C4 I
calculated this sign with Queen to E3
and I thought that I have good chances
to win now because okay I'm threatening
to take and take I also have ideas of
Queen to A7 and then just infiltrate and
if I can win the G7 pawn and maybe the
H6 Pawn then things can very quickly
just crumble for black but my opponent
was still very resourceful he played the
move Knight takes E4 allowing Queen A7
and then he plays King to
D6 and I think this is around the point
where we
reached oh no we're we're still three
moves away from move 40 um so yeah here
I play King to G2 I should note that if
I take on
G7 I think this is just a terrible
blunder because Queen E1 and I'm losing
F2 that will come with check so I had to
be very very careful King G2 was
essentially a preparatory move uh I
wanted to make sure Queen E1 doesn't
come with check and it keeps my options
open what I want to do with this queen
um also put the pressure back on my
opponent he had less than a minute to
make his next move he played the move
Queen C5 which I think was a very good
practical decision it could very well be
the best move in the position offering
the queen trade and also taring the F2
pawn and then from here I give a check
and after King to
C7 yeah I I played Queen B7 which was
the 40th move so we both got an
additional half hour at this point and
then I took some time and realized that
I can't really play for a win like I'm
currently down a pawn and if I try and
cash in on G7 and first of all F2 is
still hanging so I do have the option of
takes takes and takes but I didn't
really see how I can play for a win here
with this outside pass Pawn um black
maybe has a move like Queen C6 to start
with to prepare
E3 um or maybe Queen D6 so instead of
going for that line I played it safe and
I played Queen
B8 and honestly when I played this move
I thought I'm just forcing repetition
because uh if the queen blocks on C8
then I just take on E5 that's bad for
black if the king moves to E7 I also
take on E5 with check and then I'll take
on F5 defending so I thought we were
just going to repeat um go back and
forth here but then uh my opponent play
Queen C7 which somehow I just didn't see
coming at least from a distance but I
was very thankful here to have a nice
resource in the position is this move
Bishop E6 and okay I played this maybe
after thinking for four or five minutes
but it's a nice resource because the
king is tied down to defending the Queen
so black has to play this or this and
then with either move I'm going to have
a follow-up check uh Queen to
D5 and um yeah that's what happened
after Ken d8 Queen D5 and there's no
Queen D6 for black black would really
like to play this move but it hangs the
a pawn with check so my opponent played
King to E7 and then I finally win back
the pawn so we're back to equal
material and when we got to this
position I still thought maybe I have
some small chances to play for win but
my opponent uh really just Consolidated
he played Knight to C5 and now Black's
position is actually pretty solid the
queen defends everything and also the
queen will eventually defend G7 if I go
after the pawn and that's basically what
happened after I play Queen G8 it does
look a little bit unstable for black
because the king is so exposed my bishop
and queen seem to be working well
together but black has a very solid
setup and after the move King D6 I
really didn't see any way to play for a
win here and I just settled on
repetition and I'm pretty sure this was
like the best path forward um I didn't
want to go crazy and risk losing so yeah
that was the game it ended peacefully
but it was a super interesting fight I
have not had a chance to analyze with
engine maybe I can uh enable engine
analysis and just quickly see if there
were any missed
opportunities uh yeah leest is
crunching Moment of Truth was it a
perfect
game look at this so beautiful it's only
crunched through a few moves
though um I might have to
refresh let's see do oh hey look at this
beautiful relatively straight
graph so I was I was slightly better I
was never winning though according to
the engine also look at this we just
play the perfect game
really
wow okay I I thought for sure there
would be like one or two mistakes or
inaccuracies or blunders especially like
when things got crazy after
F5 so do I have any chance is F5
C4 engine slightly prefers Queen A1 I
mean it's probably a draw I considered
Queen
A1 um I saw King F6 yeah and I I didn't
want to go crazy with F4 here there's
some like interesting lines but then my
king gets exposed as
well so um I think I'll leave it that uh
I'll leave a link to the leest study or
broadcast if people want to analyze on
their own and maybe tell me everything
that I I maybe missed but um yeah I
guess I can't complain with the first
game pretty clean and I mean I'll be
honest that I was super super tired
during the game uh like having not gone
uh sleep since 400 a.m. uh so I was I
was trying to survive I had like the
strongest coffee that they offered um
but hopefully I'll be able to sleep
tonight and get rest for tomorrow yeah
tomorrow is round two it's a game a day
again I'll leave links in the video
description if you want to check out the
broadcast the um the tournament website
my twitch Channel where Jonathan TR will
be doing commentary big shout out to
Jonathan do send him some love but yeah
I'm I'm really tired now I'm going to
get some sleep thanks for watching I'll
see you guys soon